nous sommes ce matin avec l'humoriste
Jérémy Ferrari bonjour Jérémy Ferrari
merci de nous accorder du temps entre
deux dates de seconde partie d'émission
et non pas à 6h30 c'est très gentil mais
à 6h30 on n'a pas d'invité personne de
se lever
à 6h30
regardez nous aussi on a sorti les
grands moyens comme par magie je me
téléporte dans le nouveau studio virtuel
pour votre nouveau bulletin météo mais
aussi climat ça débute ce soir il y a
plein de nouveautés il y a plein de
surprises c'est tout neuf et c'est avec
la star de la météo évidemment Anaïs by
dénir bonjour Anaïs bonjour Julien
qu'est-ce qui nous attend alors ce soir
dans ce nouveau bulletins alors on aura
bien sûr nos prévisions habituelles mais
on va remettre cette vidéo dans un
contexte de changement climatique on va
donner des clés de compréhension on est
le 13 mars et les pompiers font déjà
face à des feux de forêt dans le sud-est
de la France 30 hectares sont partis en
fumée à briançonnée c'est dans
l'arrière-pays niçois un feu qui est
fixé ce matin 20 hectares également à
Saint-Vallier de Thiès dans la même
région deux incendies ce weekend donc
dans le sud-est ou pompier et élu
s'inquiète de cette sécheresse
himmerdale Cédric flocht rapporteur de
premier édition et justement à Perpignan
à Perpignan pourquoi à Perpignan parce
que on s'en remet au Dieu pour implorer
la pluie il y a une procession Cédric
fache qui va être organisée à la fin de
la semaine au départ de la cathédrale de
Perpignan et on va même sortir les
reliques de saint-gaudériques il pleut
des verres en Chine des vers V e r e s
ou des verres V e r s des vrais verres
un peu comme des vers de terre imaginez
en fin de journée vous sortez du travail
vous allez prendre votre voiture pour
rentrer chez vous qui est garée dans la
rue et là vous avez ça vous avez des
centaines voire des milliers de sur les
voitures c'était il y a quelques jours à
Pékin en Chine qu'est-ce qui va se
passer exactement samedi alors arrivant
de du centre-ville la procession va
franchir ici le pont Joffre et descendre
sur les berges de la tête
ici et bien le brancard portant le buste
reliquaire de Saint-Gaudéric sera porté
dans le lit de la tête par les
agriculteurs et nous le prierons pour
obtenir la pluie alors c'est un
phénomène météorologique rare mais connu
on le connaît on l'apprend à l'École
nationale de la météorologie en fait
c'est quand il y a du vent fort voir des
tornades ou des troncs marines ça
soulève les petits animaux par exemple
dans les buissons les arbres des verbes
ceci et ça les déplace de dizaines de
kilomètres c'est déjà arrivé avec des
poissons ici c'est avec des poissons au
dessus de l'océan des mers il peut y
avoir des trombes marines ici en
Australie qui prennent mais on déplace
de ça ça peut arriver certains ça peut
arriver même avec des iguanes
c'est le film kenzoscars
la cérémonie s'est déroulée ouais je
suis pas très la cérémonie s'est
déroulée cette nuit à Los Angeles le
grand favori de la compétition qui
raconte le surmenage d'une propriétaire
de laverie sommet de sauvé une multitude
d'univers parallèles
c'est complètement farfelu mais c'est
bien sympa comment déjà
one c'est le favori Everything
Everywhere all at one j'arrive pas le
film avait 11 nominations ils ont
remporté 7 Oscars dans les catégories
Rennes meilleur film rire réalisateur
meilleur montage meilleur scénario
meilleure actrice pour Michel Yéo vous
voyez les images avec son mari français
Jean Todd qui lui saute dans les bras
n'avaient jamais été nommé avant
première actrice d'origine asiatique a
remporté c'est très compensé 95 ans de
cérémonie Everything Everywhere a-t-on
Everything Everywhere all out Worms
excusez-moi il y a pas de doute on n'est
pas en Californie Sofia RAM c'est une
jeune fille
fait des chroniques sur France Inter bon
alors sachez-le c'est chronique
sont censés de drôles c'est le problème
qu'on a ça fait des années qui est le
fait toujours pas trouvé ce qu'il y
avait drôle et ce matin encore parlé de
nous et elle a parlé de la séquence avec
Gérard Forest
et tout c'est un personnage gros
couleurs qui dit des choses parfois
voilà qui farfelus
il fait grand bruit
la télé mais quand je la regardais je
voulais des gens dont je me disais oh je
ferai au moins aussi bien non on s'en
[__]
[Musique]
de parler
de nom vous je pourrais faire une énième
chronique sur les dangers d'une bande
d'abruti congénitaux ricanant sur
commode aux alentours d'un beauf et
talons son inculture sur l'autoroute de
son auto
on comprend pas ce que tu dis Sofia là
c'est pas bon là là tu là tu sais pas
bon on comprend rien ce que tu dis parce
que ça part en insulte s'il y a autant
de responsables politiques pour
continuer légitimer ce crétin ou
participant ses émissions ce n'est pas
de sa faute Sofia RAM bien sûr elle aime
bien chef de rang des suceurs du
gouvernement à la descente la Citroën
amie bridée à 45 km/h se renverse
heureusement sans faire de blesser grave
à l'intérieur le conducteur de 16 ans et
son passager âgé de 22 ans ne souffre
que de contusions légères l'accident
aurait pu être
dramatique d'autant qu'il était
prévisible au vu des nombreuses
smartphones prêt à filmer la scène
le S maintenant un vrai bouffon qui
avait la cour pour terrain de jeu
Richard Le Fou du Roi oui le problème
c'est que je voulais pas le faire
normalement je touche pas de nouveaux
habits ni à la famille mais je suis
obligé
Sofia tu sais nous au moins tu sais on
est je vais dire on est honnête voilà
mais toi franchement
occupe-toi de ta maman ma chérie
Khadija Haram qui a été condamné à deux
ans de prison de 6 mois ferme pourquoi
elle est accusée d'avoir berné des
personnes en situation régulière en leur
faisant miroiter un titre de séjour
moyennant finance alors qu'elle était
adjointe au maire de Trappes voilà pas
beau ça
[Musique]
sur ma route j'ai vu la pure un écrite
et
j'ai
crié pour ceux qui se sont sacrifiés
j'ai vu la mort de Marie et ramasser ce
qui reste des lorsque certains
consistants menacé de porter plainte
elle aurait tenté de les rembourser avec
le chéquier de l'association femme de
Trappes dont elle était présidente
Sophia tu as déjà du boulot avec ta
famille à genoux
je te dis occupe-toi d'abord de ta
famille si c'est trop là tu vois tu te
fais du mal après on va devoir me
rappeler tous les jours c'est
insupportable je suis pas là je suis
j'en ai pas au commissariat ici je vais
pas mettre la photo de ta famille
derrière moi avec tout ce qu'ils ont
fait c'est pas bon je suis pas là pour
ça ma chérie ça c'est Mozart qui disait
ça quand on lui demandait qu'est-ce que
vous prenez parce qu'il y avait souvent
boire un coup je Sébastien Marc ça c'est
vrai c'est une vraie histoire à Vienne
et quand le serveur lui disait qu'est-ce
que vous voulez je sais pas toujours un
petit whisky et un bébé et l'autoriser
qu'est-ce que vous voulez il disait un
bébé come back